[Music]
all right I know this looks bad but
seriously it's not what it looks like
all right it's exactly what it looks
like in the time of the cleaner crisp
streamlined image anime has now it may
be easy to forget that one point it went
through a phase where was this super
weird underground thing it was rough it
was experimental pushing boundaries of
acceptability and one of the hallmarks
in the late 80s and 90s was the advent
of hyper violent extremely sexualized
obeys like anime was going through an
edgy rebellious period this is not to
say that the quality of anime is any
better than what we have now for this
completely raw unhinged feeling was
something I didn't realize I hadn't felt
in years until I saw Netflix's Devilman
cry-baby that released a few days ago
this shows the breath of fresh air in
every sense of the word from the visual
style to the soundtrack to the brutal
uncensored nature - whoa whoa whoa I am
getting way ahead of myself
devil man cry-baby not to be confused
with a devil may cry baby is the latest
anime produced by Netflix marking a
high-profile government adaptation given
the franchise the attention it deserves
for the exactly 12 devil man fans that
have been shouting about it before this
existed don't forget that demons exist
and are trying to [__] humans out the
world akira Fudo is a shy virgin [__]
boy who's one day reunited with his
childhood friend Rio Oscar who you know
seems like a pretty stand-up guy I mean
I know I'd want to be friends with him
he's RI once you get to know him informs
a cura of demons and enlist his help to
try and document and prove their
existence to do so they go to an
underground party with a lot of demon
activity a place where the satanic cult
pissing about doing the most outlandish
illegal [__] while dancing about he
would find the dead aka a Saturday night
with Logan Paul that's right baby where
he got topical jokes Oh after snorting
some mad coke and a quick session of
casual manslaughter this is the
scientists are the all-you-can-eat
buffet forcing akira to fees with a
demon while still maintaining his human
heart finalizing his transformation to
the satan trap and so starts the
adventures of the new Acura Fudo as he
battles the demons that are terrorizing
humans now equipped with a powerful
demon body
and a fresh panic at this go album this
is the latest director outing from
masaaki yuasa and to go ahead and spoil
the title to my own video I just really
thought it was a [__] great show that
people should be watching so I wants to
get the word out as I was saying would
immediately call my attention which I
shall fresh this series feels
what sets Lucifer lad crybaby apart is
that it doesn't feel like a product of
this current era of anime which does
make sense considering the original
manga by gonna guys over 40 years old
now with many many many adaptations
already all of the most upmost quality
is it okay for me to wear my shoes in
here I don't give a [__] but that's not
to say that the show feels old in fact
they've done a great job in modernizing
this story to fit within the modern age
from masaaki yuasa strip II visual style
to the fantastic OST that is just mmm
do you remember what I said in my music
and anime video about a unique score
bringing so much personality to a show
well
I mean these tracks set the tone
perfectly while also making you feel
like massacring some demons or [__]
some mad [__] which is exactly what
happens not to mention the completely
uncensored violence and sex that you
just don't get to see an anime anymore
probably because the entire broadcast
would end up looking something like this
you'd be hard-pressed to find a show
that feels this unique this winter
season health probably this whole year
but being unique shouldn't be the only
reason you guys watch it so I should
stress this is not an anime for everyone
I repeat this is not an anime for
everyone the series does not shy away
from ultra violent scenes that range
from the grotesque to downright weird
and it's as horny as a teenage boy who's
just discovered pornhub wait did someone
say horny contrary to popular belief if
you don't have the stomach for it or
simply don't like the brutal and
uncensored nature of the show you don't
have to force your way through it people
won't think any differently of you
except that you're a [__] parsnip sex
and violence is sure to turn some people
off and that's completely fine but what
is unfair is the user has a point of
criticism to love this show with the
countless other anime they use it purely
for shock value or quote-unquote edgy
entertainment the brutal violence and
highly sexualized content complements
the darker unforgiving themes that come
later because if you can't handle the
vulgar content at the beginning then the
[__] and it's meant to make you
uncomfortable it's done in a way that's
absolutely tasteless because the series
sack was some dark depressing subject
matters that aren't pleasant for anyone
while the series starts off as more of a
formulaic monster-of-the-week show when
it really shines in the latter half when
it shifts into something much bigger we
start to explore themes of mass hysteria
discrimination and the foil of
civilization that can be for the human
race with a single spark we start seeing
the absolute darkest side of mankind
with order destruction that comes with
it and while I think these are
interesting ideas what makes it really
hit home other characters what's always
tried to be about you asses works isn't
just as visuals but the Kari puts into
his characters you can feel a genuine
love with the youthful spirit as he
portrays his characters with a lot of
heart through the best and worst of
times the characters in the show even
the supporting ones were given a lot of
care to make them feel extremely human
but this is what makes the adaptation so
genuine thinking about the writing the
characters are actually quite simplistic
the anime gave them a lot of subtle
characterization that humanized them
it's these extremely human
characteristics and reactions juxtaposed
against the absolutely inhumane
situations that made for some moments
that were truly inspiring and heartfelt
while others being absolutely
soul-crushing the only reason I'm even
making this video is because some bits
left such a deep impression on me that
my mind would not let me focus on
anything else until I talked about it as
I said the series is not for the faint
of heart and I can see how the original
work was so influential that would
inspire such classics as berserk and
Evangelion another aspect I want to
bring up is the trippy abstract visuals
now for the record I'm a huge fan of
masaaki yuasa
his all style is one of the most unique
and expressive things to come out of
anime in the modern era
and while Devilman is actually one of
his more subdued pieces of work
comparatively he still brings his a-game
because when it hits it [__] you hey
however the big issue I've always had
with all this works is that I can never
tell when if I think something looks bad
if it's meant to look bad or is it a
creative choice and I'm always wrestling
with this because I'm the best of times
it's like haha and then an X evening can
be like if I had any other complaints is
that the series switch gears a bit too
abruptly going from the odd edgy demon
battle to in about five seconds and I
would have loved an episode to really
explore the transition between the two
stages also I've heard a lot of people
complaining about the ending but I
actually really enjoyed it without
spoiling I feel after the events that
played out you could only have really
ended one way and I did everything I set
out to do which not everyone may like
but it was an entirely fitting
conclusion that actually ended less
abruptly than the original manga last
thing I want to bring up is netflix
finally bringing something to the table
not counting the western productions of
neo yo kyo and castlevania this marks
the first time a Netflix original anime
has actually meant they are the sole
platform inside and outside Japan
instead of just being like hey I see you
got in your anime coming out mind if you
buy the international streaming rights
oh sure
all right well we're gonna slap a
Netflix original logo in it
you cool with that uh but we're on
Japanese TV and you didn't make us I'm
sorry what was that we said you didn't
make up say your name what say it
we don't say your name Netflix original
anime your god damn and this is a sign
of things to come I am very excited to
see what the future holds because
currently Devilman is an anime that I
cannot see existing on any other
platform aside from Netflix right now
it's too brutal to air on TV and perhaps
even too rough and uncensored for
something that crunchyroll and
Funimation with reading wants a push and
market and that's what makes it so
exciting
Netflix have provided a legitimately new
platform that fits in its own space
within the enemy's sphere and not only
that but one of the most unique and
attention-grabbing anime to come out in
the past few years was only made
possible because it had a platform on
the most mainstream media outlet around
right now something that's quite out
there even for anime fans might not have
even had a chance to be made had anime
not grown popular enough internationally
for a platform like this to give it a
chance and I think that's pretty [__]
cool how good is Antichrist fellow
crybaby [__] good regardless of how
unique and fresh it feels within this
current era of anime it is a story that
has stood the test of time adapted to
the modern era and I can definitely see
how the source material is a classic
that has inspired many influential anime
that came after it it's brutal its
Hornung it's one hell of a ride so if
anyone deserves this big Toblerone it's
you don't man go and be a good boy to
eat the toad
take it to eat the Toblerone but [__]
eat it
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to lis
what may teaming up on our big Black
Hawk 60 sisters one zero zero eight six
LFO Robert hardball and everyone else on
patreon bellies
hoping this month and making this video
possible hope you've had a great new
year I've just come back from a holiday
myself since the year-end reviews and
just the whole December white like
almost killed me so it's good to be back
hopefully you don't mind just a casual
quick video like this while I get back
into the groove of things I'm all rest
and recovered now though so I'm very
excited to get back to work and make
some more videos so anyway until then
I've been diggin and I will see you all
next time